I joined Pacman Dotcom a we have a great place
to discuss politics with fellow viewers. It
is The David Pakman Show sub. Read it at David
Pakman dot com slash. Read it. That's r e
d d i t. About twenty one thousand. If you
can imagine, 21000 of our viewers and listeners
are subscribed free to the David Pakman show
sub Reddit users sneaky get posted that white
supremacist David Duke has endorsed Tucker
Carlson as vice president. You know, David
Duke always endorses someone and I hesitate
to make too much of it. I know a lot in my
audience wanted me to talk about this and
point out this proves that he's a white supremacist.
I'm pretty sure David Duke endorsed Tulsi
Gabbard. That doesn't mean Tulsi is a white
supremacist. David Duke. Always does this.
And I think it's important not to I mean,
you know, Hitler breathe the oxygen, right?
That's the that's where I go on this. And
I wouldn't really make too much of it. Obviously,
I agree that Tucker Carlson has fed xenophobic
and white supremacist ideas on his program.
One of his writers was recently fired for
being discovered to have been posting racist
things under a pseudonym on the Internet.
I'm not denying anything about what we know
about Tucker Carlson. I just don't think we
should pay too much attention to David Duke
endorsing this person or that or that person.
In a lot of ways, it's just David Duke trying
to get himself attention. User cremation.
Lilly posted a very interesting graph that
shows the correlation between corona virus
cases and political leanings. And when you
look at the data, you very clearly see that
the places with the most severe outbreaks
now are overwhelmingly what we would call
red states, whereas it is blue states that
are doing better right now. Now, this is going
by governor. Now, this is a little tricky
because Massachusetts for, for example, has
a Republican governor who is one of the more
moderate Republicans in the country. And we
have one of the most left wing legislatures
in the country. So to put massive Massachusetts
by all measures really is a blue state. But
in any case, this gives us an idea that you
had the early hot spots when it came to Corona
virus and those were really related to places
with early infections, mostly because of a
lot of direct flights to and from the prior
hot spots, meaning China and places in Europe.
We didn't really know what we were doing at
that point. We're now five months in. And
now what you're seeing is a divide based on
state policy. And very clearly the places
that are doing better have a certain set of
policies at the state level. And the graph
certainly confirms that. And then lastly,
Steel 014 posted an important question about
Donald Trump's urgent press conference earlier
this week, asking, has a president ever called
an urgent, previously unannounced press conference
to basically attack, baselessly attack his
political opponent in a completely incoherent
manner for an hour straight and then only
take three questions. One question coming
from right wing propaganda network. Oh, and
the answer is no. You know, I didn't I didn't
really have to rack my brain thinking no other
president has done that. And we have a press
briefing scheduled for today, which I expect
to be yet another just absolute Gong Show.
And now what we're seeing is unprecedented
panic from Donald Trump. I'm losing. Give
me a piece of paper with criticisms of Biden.
Let me go out there and read it for an hour.
I'm losing. Let me replace my campaign manager
with only three and a half months to go. These
are signs of desperation and we've not seen
a lot of this before. Join the discussion
at David Pakman dot com slash. Read it. his
is free. I'm selling you nothing. It's just
a place to discuss the news and politics of
the day with other David Pakman show viewers
and listeners.